what are you doing  scammers say hello hello George  Bamberger Serena Shaw I think we should  be married never thought I'd find you I  never thought I'd find anyone how much  is yours house  I sure would like to know what you think  of our little aberration I think you've  taken nine months to do about six months  work can you find a wife or a partner  well I'm afraid your stocks are no  longer sufficient collateral off your  chef everything that we talked about we  will lose it we promise to tell each  other everything I didn't want to  frighten you I'm not that kind of woman  they're not the same anymore the only  thing that's changed is you don't forget  about everything buddy John  you have a son  you lie  I'd like to speak to your wife there's a  murder last night  you need to get a far away from these  mountains you can  you betrayed you don't  everything you did you did for us  I can't lose you